oui bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
jacques une petite aux invités ce matin
dans 16 autres cas dit bonjour oui bon
jeu et bonjour à tous les auditeurs de
nantes eric la première voilà avec vous
nous allons parler de cette lettre
ouverte et publique de deux martiniquais
une lettre cosignée à l'heure où on
parle par 100 citoyennes et citoyens
d'ici une lettre ouverte donc je disais
adressé aux et là je cite l'appellation
usité par ses cosignataires adressée aux
préfets gouverneurs de martinique alors
jacques une petite au d'abord pourquoi
cette appellation connoté riz alors
cette appellation connoté disant que les
qui n'a pas gêné en tout cas les
signataires c'est parce que beaucoup
d'entre nous ne considérons pas que nous
soyons disons un territoire français
disons classique m et que nous sommes
une colonie l'objet du courrier est en
tête 1 pour un retour à la vie normale
c'est donc une revendication qui est
présente et donc à un stanislas cazelles
préfet donc de martinique que la plupart
des avis scientifiques médicaux jacques
une petite eau en tout cas ce que nous
pouvons consulter ou entendre ici ou là
indique que l'épidémie de kovy de 19 est
encore loin d'être terminé alors cette
revendication de d'un retour à la vie
normale ce qu'elle ait pas précoce est
en décalage avec des situations telles
que présentées effectivement par les
autorités les professionnels de santé
publique y compris d'ailleurs le ms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
n'a pas que nous sachions annoncé et
encore moins déclarer la fin de la
pandémie
alors pourquoi un retour à la vie
normale là tout de suite dès maintenant
oui alors disons qu'on peut considérer
qu'il y a effectivement un problème
sanitaire et qu'il y a dix ans une
épidémie mais elle est présentée de
manière complètement catastrophique
et comme nous l'écrivons dans la lettre
ouverte un nous faisons très nettement
une distinction
on fait même distinction qualitative
entre des scientifiques
disons qu'ils ne sont pas qu'ils n'ont
pas de conflit d'intérêts avec des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et les
scientifiques
qui sont subordonnés à ses laboratoires
alors nous avons pris connaissance avec
énormément de dison d'espoir 1 de la
constitution d'un collectif de collectif
de médecins de soignants de
scientifiques qui ils ont fait une
conférence de presse le 9 janvier
dernier ils ont lancé ce qu'ils ont
appelé un appel du 9 juin
et ils sont sur cette position là alors
ils demandent par exemple que tous les
médecins n'ayant pas de conflit
d'intérêt le déclare et enfin les
scientifiques et des médecins et que
ceux qui ont des conflits d'intérêts
avec les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
plaisir c'est lundi que 7 pouces pour
des intérêts économiques de 2,2 je
dirais de spéculation pour pouvoir faire
des bénéfices finalement absolument oui
on a certains auraient peut être
amplifiée augmenté donc là comment
dirais-je l'impact de cette affaire
et puis les mines tout à fait et
d'ailleurs que ce ce regroupement qui
regroupe donc qui n'est pas du tout
marginale 1 30 mille médecins 30000
soignants cent mille citoyens et bien
ils demandent notamment ils ont décidé
notamment de constituer une cellule
statistiques parce que selon eux les
statistiques sont falsifiés et nous
l'indiquons d'ailleurs dans l'autre les
trouver atteindre présent par ce qui
concerne la martinique
certains d'entre nous ont mené une
enquête sur le chiffre de 49 qui avait
été annoncée par le directeur de la rs
et les personnels hospitaliers et bien
ont indiqué que cas plus de 46 49
déclaré n'avait pas pathologie à coup
vide donc nous considérons qu'il y à une
amplification pour pouvoir justement
amenée à hama où il grandir et de
manipulations absolument une
manipulation il a les relations de
laquelle il pourrait y avoir d d d d
intérêt économique nous avons nous avons
d'ailleurs eu des témoignages un petit
peu sordide un de gens
qui ont perdu des parents et on leur a
demandé de déclarer ce qui n'était pas
vrai que leurs parents étaient morts dus
qu'aux vide et en retour de quoi ils ont
eu leurs obsèques prise en charge
jacqueline plus tôt alors le temps passe
très vite
dans ce courrier après un large dyson à
une analyse des dix derniers mois qu'on
décale la population martiniquaise a eu
elle aussi à affronter cette situation
de crise sanitaire social économique et
c'est alors une période d'ailleurs sur
laquelle vous poser un regard très
critique mais bon voilà malheureusement
nous n'avons pas le temps d'y revenir
cependant vous écrivez dans cette lettre
ouverte et publique à au préfet de
martinique vous écrivez que vous vous
êtes de ceux qui font confiance aux
spécialistes honnête alors vous c'est ce
que vous avez dit interdite
j'estime qu'il n'ya pas de pandémie mais
vous dites aussi que vous êtes de ceux
qui pensent et ça rejoint un peu ce que
vous disiez à l'instant que c'est
délibérément cyniquement je vous cite là
nous sommes de ceux qui pensent que
c'est délibérément cyniquement et
machiavéliquement que les différents
gouvernements dont le vôtre donc celui
de la france quad de jean castex et ceux
qui l'ont précédé et bien que vous êtes
des fidèles défenseurs des intérêts du
grand capital acquis le marché de la
santé offre des profits faramineux et
qu' ils organisent un scénario
catastrophe afin dit vous de museler les
populations et de vendre des vaccins
douteux voilà et parfois peut-être
certains pourraient vous reprocher ou
simplement noté constater que vous
reprenez avancé des arguments voisins
voire même parfois très proche de thèse
désigné à tort ou à raison
selon les opinions d une idée des uns et
des autres comme complotistes est ce
qu'on dit le complotisme etc
mais vous jacques une petite eau par
exemple vous êtes enseignant
universitaire militante politique
notamment concernant la défense des
droits humains
bon voilà des des ouvriers aussi tout ça
est ce que ça vous dérangerait d'être
peu ou prou associés voire même assimilé
disons à cette tendance de notre société
cette tendance deux thèses complotistes
oui c'est à dire que bon c'est pas
l'appeler pour mouiller - c'est-à-dire
peut il y avoir il ya souvent disons que
souvent dix ans ce qu'ils sont
ceux qui ne suivent pas disons les
directives la doxa de l'ordre établi son
calomnier alors donc ils peuvent
raconter ce qu'ils veulent mais nous
prétendants et vous pas les 100
signataires nous prétendons nous situer
du côté de la vérité 1 et contre toute
forme de manipulation et ce que nous ce
que nous revendiquons si d'ailleurs ce
que revendique que ce fameux collectif
qui a sorti un manifeste et un déjà à ce
jour soixante quatorze mille signatures
c'est la totale vérité et la
transparence
par exemple nous disons qu'il est très
important que ceux qui par exemple
défend de la marche forcée d'ailleurs à
la vaccination dise clairement si oui ou
non ils ont des conflits d'intérêts avec
les trusts formes pharmaceutiques 1 nous
demandons la transparence et nous
pensons qu'il faut absolument qu'il y
ait lock on le principe du
contradictoire et nous ne le craignons
pas et d'ailleurs nous trouvons très
bien que mon unique la première joue ce
jeu est notamment dans l'émission e
résonance au niveau télévision je tiens
à indiquer que ça ne semble pas être la
position du gouvernement parce que un
décret a été pris en catimini le 23
décembre dernier interdisant la libre
parole à des médecins alors si on est en
train tadla vers un véritable
totalitarisme nous disons qu'ils font là
la transparence de manière que les
intéressés puissent pouvoir choisir en
toute liberté et en toute logique on va
laisser le calme et le et dites moi le
vaccin officiellement oui n'est pas si
chacune de vouloir soyez administrés ou
pas enfin de le faire administrer des
regrets vaccine pas moi-même tout cas
voilà c est le principe qui est posée
livia il y a par contre des chantages
absolument odieux j'ai reçu hier un
témoignage qui m'a bouleversé
2 1 quelqu'un qui est qui a un parent
dialysés et à qui on a fait le chantage
suivant si vous voulez poursuivre votre
dialyse
vous devez vous vacciner cela se passe
en martinique est selon nous nous
estimons que ceci est passible de
poursuites
cela c'est de l'extorsion de postes de
consentement et nous invitons tous ceux
qui sont sujets à ce sondage comme ceux
qui sont dans les ehpad en ce moment et
à qui on dit si vous ne vous faites pas
vacciner
eh bien vous n'irez pas à la cantine
avec des autres vous n'irez pas en
sortir si terra c'est du chantage qui
mérite des poursuites judiciaires au
sein des cosignataires êtes vous toutes
et tous anti vaccins par principe
c'est à dire contre le principe de la
vaccination quelles que soient les les
vaccins voilà où est ce que donc contre
tous les vaccins ou est ce que c'est ce
vaccin là où ces vaccins la du moment
qu'ils sont censés c'est comme ça qu'on
nous le présente censées être liées à la
lutte contre le kof de et notamment à
atténuer les effets graves de la maladie
l'a de l'aco vide elles n'ont
certainement pas et disons pour ce qui
nous concerne personnellement je
considère au le vaccin comme pour
extrêmement important pour l'humanité
mais sauf que le vaccin doit être
administré avec une application du
principe de précaution et c'est un
vaccin en qu'elle en fait on l'on
appelle max vaccin d'ailleurs les
spécialistes disent thérapie génique et
qui est complètement nouveau qui peut
même provoquer des modifications de
l'adn ce n'est pas n'importe quoi donc
le faire ainsi dans tous les publics au
centre d'heather 8 d'autres contredisent
m'enfin c'est un débat et c'est un
risque à part c'est un risque
c'est un risque est alors donc nous
considérons que il l'est
irresponsable on pourrait même dire
criminellement irresponsable de
l'administrer ainsi à marche forcée sega
thouars vous dit que finalement on a
quatre mais il y à des risques énormes
il est même certain en même émis l'idée
de licencier les personnels soignants
qui seraient réfractaires à cette
vaccination alors une c'est un scandale
absolu
il nous faut conclure vous récurrent de
demande y est aussi la réouverture de
l'université
oui j'avais petit tout avait été remis
quelques nouvelles là-dessus vraiment
quelques secondes
oui bien sûr et bien dressé dès que nous
avons été en contact avec la présidente
l'association solidaire des étudiants de
martinique qui demandaient la
réouverture de l'université donc nous
l'avons intégrée dans cette lettre
ouverte et nous nous félicitons que
cette réouverture ait pu avoir les pu
avoir avec toutes les difficultés mais
enfin nous terminons sur cette note
d'espoir en quelque sorte merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
si moins à la merci